linear uh a difficult match against Sam
Shanklin the player that has incredible
theoretical knowledge what did you
expect from this match and how did you
get ready for it yeah I mean I expected
him to be as usual very well preparing
the opening
um so I was more or less expecting than
either that's what he played against me
the last couple of times
and so uh yeah we got into some unusual
position after this 96 H3 and then
um out of six Bishop B3 E5 and then this
taken on C6 and F4 is interesting I
remember
this was kind of challenging for black
and then I think the end game that we
got is just slightly worse for black
it is but he was also speeding through
these moves he was playing very very
yeah he was playing very fast I don't
know if I mean I maybe he knew this
position but I mean I also knew that
it's kind of pleasant for white so I was
just trying to make sure that I done uh
blow it right away because there were
there was Bishop A5 ideas but but yeah I
mean I think the point here Bishop to A5
or yeah I mean when I play long castle
if Bishop A5 uh no instead of Bishop B6
but then I can just go Knight A4 and if
Knight E4 I Bishop B6 and this should be
very good for white
takes and then takes on C8 and takes on
A6 and there is Bishop B7 and okay Rook
H1 just to interrupt you for one second
uh and as it did draw her game her
second game against and wins the match
eliminates Tate from the competition and
moves on to the semifinals
let's keep going
yeah this this wasn't good for black and
yeah here I'm slightly better I wasn't
sure about Knight H5 Knight F4 I mean it
looks active but the Knight is actually
not doing much on F4 and then there's no
pressure on on e4 so I can I think
Bishop of one was correct and I'm coming
with Rook D6 and Knight C5 and this was
just uh I think a blunder yeah this was
the move yeah allowed you to go G3 did
he miss Bishop to B6 was this maybe yeah
I don't know yeah I think maybe he
missed the whole idea that I can just
move the bishop because even after
something like Bishop C5 is still losing
something
this is a much better version but I can
take play Knight C3 and and the night is
anyway lost controls the D1 Square the
Knight is lost on H3 yeah this looks so
I think that uh I can move the bishop
yeah but still yeah easy yeah still a
fight I mean I'm completely winning but
somehow this pawns you never know where
they might uh arrive he gave you the man
here yeah I was trying to be very
precise I don't know I mean I I decided
to play the the really
uh brute move Bishop F2 uh but yeah I'm
sure like they're like we like this one
yeah but it's very practical just to get
rid of the Bishops I mean try one more
uh piece and
um yeah it's raining all along I mean
there are some tricks with H3 at some
point but it's just too obvious and even
though I had little time I came to E3
yeah yeah this was the line H2 Rook H1
and G2 there's rookies to check yeah
okay to check and then pick up the Rook
on G5 that's yeah or pick up the pawn on
G2 very nicely done linear and after
that
the second game you play the Petrov a
very stable defense nevertheless once
again he was speeding he actually gained
two minutes on his clock at some point
he had 27 minutes oh yeah and he had 11
minutes on your clock did you feel any
pressure
um I mean of course I wasn't happy about
the fact that I was like uh 15 minutes
down but on the other hand the position
was a bit simplified I knew I mean this
cannot be so bad and I was very happy
with rookie E8 I thought this was a
precise move because I mean Bishop C6
feels wrong I mean queen D3 and then
there is Bishop H6 so Bishop D2 Rook a
one coming but I think after Rook 88 uh
my position should be
um just to just completely fine and even
though I had much less time again it's a
it's not such a difficult position
because now it's more or less clear what
I'm doing and that probably like
straight some pieces yeah and and I
think I was never really in danger after
that Lanier congratulations is a very
clinical performance from you today you
move on to the next match you still have
one life left in the event who do you
prefer from uh Fabi or Lavon yeah I
don't know it's of course they're pretty
pretty equal I mean in the the match
itself it's it's just
um unpredictable what will happen so
yeah I'm happy to to face uh any of any
of them yeah guys any questions yeah
absolutely uh first of all our
congratulations to yourself Lanier but I
love the rebranding of your image I mean
the black leather jacket man this is
this is cool uh is this something new
yeah it worked somehow so I'll probably
keep it going
well it sure makes you look like a tough
guy I gotta tell you
good luck in your next match thank you
absolutely wow and uh Alice